[Music]
I am not me now
you are what I made you
I was abducted by the RDA
and trained in their ways
15 years they kept me from my world and
my people
oh wait
you have the mark
you are Sorrento
the poor child knows nothing of our ways
let home tree be a refuge from your
burdens
I must seek those who can teach me the
ways of the not be and help me reconnect
with my world
follow me
for you
not
[Music]
you are starting to think like a Nazi
now we will teach you to ride like one
Pandora is under attack again
I will not allow the RDA to destroy this
land
this is my home
[Music]
just the RDA
and nothing and I will protect Pandora
[Music]
PlayStation